interviewer: All right, so can
you start off by giving us
a little introduction
to your applications
and your company?
de Halleux: Sure. My name
is Sebastien de Halleux.
I'm one of the founder
of Playfish,
and we are
a social games company,
so we make games for friends
to play together
in a social context.
So what we're here
to announce today
is one of our most popular game,
which is a top-ten game
on Facebook,
called
"Who Has The Biggest Brain?"
released for the first time
on Android.
And this is very exciting,
because, for the first time,
you can play
with your real-life friends
on your Android phone.
So you start the game,
you're given
four 60-second tests,
which spits out, you know,
how big a brain you have
in cubic centimeters
in a very unscientific way,
and then the fun starts
by comparing that score
with your real-life friends
on Facebook via a Facebook
connecting permutation.
And that's really exciting,
because you see
pictures of your friends
on your Android phone,
and you can play
anytime anywhere.
Um, so this is the first title
that we're announcing,
but we have a range of titles
that are coming on Android.
Overall, Playfish has around
30 million monthly active users
playing our games, so, you know,
there's a huge community
that really wants to extend
the experience from the web
onto their Android devices.
interviewer: All right.
So, can you tell us a little bit
about your decision to use
the Android platform?
de Halleux: Absolutely.
So, you know,
the Playfish founding team
has really deep roots in mobile.
We've been doing games on
mobile phones since about 2001,
and one of the key reasons
why we sort of moved away
from the mobile platform
and onto the web platform
was for distribution.
And now that Android,
you know, comes into being
as an open platform on mobile,
we are incredibly excited
to bring back, you know,
some of the best of the web
when it comes to distribution,
marketplace, and connectivity
on the internet,
allowing to connect
to third-party APIs,
something that's
always been very hard to do
in a standard mobile ecosystem.
So, you know, those
distribution decisions were key
you know, for us to move
on to the Android platform.
In addition, you know,
the great interface,
the touch screen, and
the relatively high-end device,
are making
for great gaming experiences.
And our game have been designed
with touch screen in mind,
so it makes it--
It makes a very compelling
end-user experience.
I think, the third aspect
is the business model.
So, you know, one thing is
you have great distribution.
The other one
is to be able to monetize
and build a business, you know,
on the mobile platform,
and traditionally,
carriers have been famous
for really, you know,
squeezing the publisher
and getting really high
revenue share for themselves,
and with Android as a platform,
the ecosystem has
been rebalanced, so to speak,
with, you know,
the revenue share
that's publicly
been announced as being 70%
for the developer,
and that's great news for us,
because that means that, rather
than spending time and money
negotiating agreements
with every single carrier,
you know, four per country,
we can focus
all our energy and budgets
on the product quality
and benefit
from the Google infrastructure
and the Android marketplace
to monetize our games.
interviewer: All right, uh,
what's the biggest challenge
you've had
on the Android platform?
de Halleux: I think, you know,
the biggest challenge is
that the platform is new,
and with new platforms come
unforeseen challenges.
You know, some are technical,
and I think, you know,
games are usually very hungry
in terms of device resources.
We've pushed, I think,
the OpenGL current capability,
you know, to their limit
in terms of getting
a high frame rate,
getting a smooth experience,
and similarly,
you know, getting audio,
getting really
time-based mechanics, you know,
that feel right for the user.
It has been
a learning experience for us.
The good news
is that what we've learned
is reusable in terms
of framework for our next game,
and so, you know, the game
which we're already working on,
is being developed, you know,
at least twice the speed,
if not more.
interviewer: All right. What's
the biggest differentiator
of Android versus
other platforms?
de Halleux: Well, you know, it's
the openness of the platform
is really
the true differentiator.
For us, you know, our web view
is around 1.5 billion people,
who are using the web
on any given day,
and there's 3.5 billion phones
out there, right?
And there's no open platform,
so I think Android
is really addressing a need
that is very, very strong for us
of offering an open platform
cheaply
to handset manufacturers.
And with the announcement,
you know, today
of the number of new handsets
that are coming,
we'll see Android
getting more traction,
and we want to be part
of that wave, you know.
We want to be one of the reasons
why people, you know,
move to Android,
and making them realize
that there's
great content available
for those open platforms.
interviewer: Uh, are there
any tips or tricks
that you were able to do
on the Android platform
that you weren't
on other platforms?
Anything fun
or interesting?
de Halleux: Um, I think,
you know, one of the great,
uh, realization of Playfish
and "Who Has the Biggest Brain?"
has been that social connection,
so the ability to create
a very, very transparent
end-user experience that,
within two clicks,
you know, connects you
to your social graph,
wherever it might be,
in this case Facebook,
you know, is
a really powerful experience,
because, suddenly, you see
your phone in a different way.
You see your phone
as a window onto the real web,
and you should see people,
when they first experience this,
there's a big "aha" moment,
going,
"Oh, you know, all my friends
who don't have
an Android device,
but are part
of my group of friends,
are suddenly invited as part
of the experience on my phone."
And that's a really cool moment.
interviewer: Right, right.
Um, what's your favorite aspect
of the Android
development process?
de Halleux: I think
it's definitely been
the development program.
You know, the team has been
incredibly supportive.
Our development has been
spread across continent,
and from London
to Mountain View.
We've had, you know,
fantastic support
to answer some
of our technical challenges,
some of which
were platform-related,
some of which were, you know,
our learning experience,
and addressing those together
has been really
a tremendous experience.
interviewer: So you have a game
that's about to be released
on iGoogle?
de Halleux: That's right.
As a matter of fact,
it is the same game
we just released on Android,
"Who Has the Biggest Brain?"
which is now available
in the sandbox of iGoogle,
using your Google friends,
so that's another social graph
we're trying to tap into.
And for people
who are using the iGoogle page,
they'll be able to find
"Who Has the Biggest Brain?"
as a gadget on the web,
um, and then they'll be able,
when they leave their PC,
to take their Android phone
and continue the experience,
and this is the exactly
same application,
so they can practice
and train their brain
and share scores
with their friends, you know,
on their phone
or on iGoogle.
interviewer: All right.
Well, I want to thank you
for your time
and sharing
your story with us.
I hope you have
a great rest of your day.
de Halleux: Great, thank you.